i co-wrote the second x-men film and
supreme returns but before that I had
written this screenplay it was my spec
scripts every writer has to do one order
to prove that they can actually write
something and it was a horror anthology
film so it's for short stories that I'll
take place on halloween night in the
same small town so unlike creep show or
tail from The Cribs where the stories
were completely unrelated to each other
the stories for the characters in these
stories actually intertwined and
crisscross into each other's hair is
this is more of a horror comedy in a way
and I use the word comedy loosely
because it's a really dark comedy it's a
little more mean-spirited funny it kind
of has that tongue-in-cheek tone of Evil
Dead II poltergeist even nightmare on
elm street is morbidly funny it's a lot
of prosthetic and animatronic effects
which occasionally get enhanced by CG
but you know we don't have any sort of
CG monsters it was a low-budget horror
film so everything had to be had to be
done looks cool the film itself doesn't
take advantage of a lot of new
technologies but what I will say is that
it's the internet that has kept still
alive it's been kind of shelved for a
couple years I finished it in 2007
literally two years ago to the day and
we had we've had screenings of it at
festivals and little special screenings
around the u.s. and it's the buzz from
those screenings which is kept the
pillow viable you know and really
creative this cult following for it
really it's a there's a whole internet
bloggers community especially horror
genre sites Anna cool news Bloody
Disgusting shocked they draw chud these
guys have really
kept the word going on the movie